die fraktionsvorsitzende im bundestag
der afd arbeit im bundestag sind ja
gemeinsam mit alexander gauland
vorsitzende der fraktion das war sehr
vorhin gesagt hat so eine art
vermächtnis von bauland für seine partei
ja das kann man so verstehen also hätte
eine sehr schöne rede gehalten für
einigkeit er möchte eben auch genau wie
ich dass wir geeint aus diesem parteitag
herausgehen
ich bin recht zuversichtlich dass wir
das auch schaffen und ja ich bin ja noch
weiterhin mit alexander gauland da eben
die große ehre weiterhin mit ihm die
bundestagsfraktionen zu führen
es ging ja in diesen in dieser
vermächtnis rede von alexander gauland
auch um die bündnisfähigkeit der partei
da hat man sicher lange her von allen
parteien abgrenzen gesagt hier wir sind
haben eine sonderrolle jetzt eine
offerte an die union und die cdu und die
csu sie wissen aus ihrer erfahrung im
bundestag die cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
ist auf die afg meistens nicht sehr gut
zu sprechen sind sie denn da in
absehbarer zeit tatsächlich eine bündnis
möglichkeit
es kommt auf die inhalte an natürlich
ist das bei einer merkel cdu oder bei
einer annegret kramp karrenbauer cdu
nicht aus denkbar wenn sich aber die cdu
irgendwann irgendwann einmal beginnt auf
die ursprünglichen werte auf die
liberal- konservativen werte auch
zurückzuziehen und sich darauf auch
zurück zu besinnen wie es beispielsweise
die werte union ja momentan verzweifelt
versucht dann können wir uns das
inhaltlich natürlich vorstellen
denn wenn wir in den osten schauen wie
die ost länder abgestimmt haben sachsen
beispielsweise da haben cdu und fdp
zusammen mehr als zwei drittel mehr als
65 66 prozent der stimmen geholt und das
ist ein wählerwillen dem man dauerhaft
nicht aus dem weg gehen kann wenn sie
koalition schmieden aus wahlverlierern
dann ist das auch aus meiner sicht nicht
demokratisch darüber müssen die parteien
auch in ihrer verantwortung nachdenken
die werte union er innerhalb der union
ja eigentlich eher eine splittergruppe
wenn ich davon wer die union nach merkel
führt wenn sie sich an die
auseinandersetzungen stefan brandmann zb
erinnern ist das nicht ein
grundsätzlicher dissens zwischen der
union und der afg der weit über personen
hinaus klick was meinen sie jetzt mit
stefan brandner
ich meine die abwahl von ihm als
rechtsausschussvorsitzende es ja auch
massive kritik an der amtsführung von
stefan brandner da wurde von er hätte
die würde des amtes nicht ausgefüllt so
könne man politisch nicht agieren ist
nicht ein viel größerer dissenz noch
sachlich zwischen fdp und cdu csu wie
man eigentlich politik betreibt und
welche akzente mehr setzen in der
öffentlichkeit
also herr brandner hat hervorragenden
ausschuss geführt an seiner inhaltlichen
führung gab es nie kritik er hatte eben
twitter-meldungen abgesetzt er hat ein
wort verwandt dass andere politiker vor
ihm aus anderen parteien auch verwandt
haben und da war es wohl den mit
fraktionen zu viel dass man das als
vorwand genommen hat um stefan partner
auch abzuwählen
wir prüfen im übrigen rechtliche
schritte dagegen vorzugehen denn das hat
es in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch gar nicht gegeben wenn
sie sagen inhaltlich es ging nicht um
die inhaltliche führung des
rechtsausschusses hat er denn die würde
des amtes verletzt durch sein verhalten
stefan brandner
ich sage ganz klar nein denn er hat ein
wort genutzt
das vor ihm viele andere politiker
genutzt haben wurde davon von allen
seiten auch aus meiner sicht diffamiert
und das ist etwas was höchst übertrieben
in der reaktion gewesen ist
sie treten ja hier auch wieder an bei
der neuwahl des der parteispitze die
besteht ja aus vorsitzende
stellvertretern und auch beisitzern
rechnen sie da auch bei ihrer kandidatur
mit widerständen dass der ein oder
andere das hat er ja hier schon
durchsickern lassen sie dass sie sich zu
nah am flügel der partei befinden dann
brücke also bei uns passiert des
grundsätzlichen allen wahlgängen dass
leute aus dem hütchen springen also ich
rechne auch bei meiner kandidatur damit
ich werde heute auf dem ersten vize
posten antreten also direkt nach den
sprechern als er
der stellvertretende bundessprecherin
und natürlich werde ich
gegenkandidaturen bekommen und was eine
annäherung an bieren höcke anbelangt so
ist das so dass wir als fraktionsführung
alle strömungen unserer fraktion haben
der flügel natürlich auch ein proporz
hat um meine aufgabe zusammen mit
alexander gauland ist immer mit allen
strömung eine kommunikation zu haben und
zusammenzuarbeiten und das funktioniert
in der bundestagsfraktion hervor ahnt es
könnte wieder ärger mit parteienfinanzen
geben bezug auf die afg das war in der
zeit bevor sie zum beispiel
fraktionsvorsitzende geworden sind sehen
sie da ungemach wieder auf die partei
zukommen da geht es um spenden die
möglicherweise gestückelt sind nicht
richtig deklariert und überhaupt nicht
deklariert könnte dass der fc in der
nächsten zeit schaden
na ja also ich habe das also diesen
spenden vorgang im detail jetzt nicht
angesehen weil es weit vor meiner zeit
gewesen ist global perspektivisch lässt
sich sagen dass unsere partei sehr viel
gelernt hat denn es wurden in der tat
fehler gemacht
es wurden gelder zurück zu gelder zurück
geführt also es wurde nicht verwandt
aber auch das war anscheinend falsch
also fehler wurden gemacht das ist aber
auch unseren strukturen zu verdanken wir
haben eigentlich nur ehrenamtliche die
unsere kompetenzen im bereich wir haben
schon längst deutlich mehr kompetenz
aufgebaut nachdem nach den
spenden beispielsweise von jürgen heute
guido reil und meine wenigkeit da geben
wir an wir haben eine spenden richtlinie
direkt danach auch aufgesetzt die hatten
wir ja vorher nicht und es ist ganz klar
wir als partei
wir haben fehler gemacht und wir
korrigieren diese fehler auch ganz klar
soweit alles so fraktionsvorsitzender im
bundestag danke mich für das gespräch